salut les ventes à l'eau aujourd'hui je
vous explique d'astuces psychologique
pour bluffer quelqu'un c'est un forçage
de cartes psychologique
alors qu'on soit bien d'accord mon but
dans cette vidéo c'est pas de vous
bluffez vous parce que vous connaissez
déjà le principe vous connaissez mon
objectif forcer quelque chose
psychologiquement
donc ça ne marchera pas sur vous puisque
vous savez voilà comme ça je les dis et
je serai sûr ne pas avoir de commentaire
à ça n'a pas marché sur moi
quoique en disant ça je vais avoir des
commentaires comme ça c'est compliqué
mon but c'est bien de vous apprendre
quelque chose de bleu font que vous
allez pouvoir reproduire et même
amélioré à votre sauce à vous je vais
vous présenter comme vous devriez le
présenter à un spectateur ou à quelqu'un
alors forcément vous pouvez le faire en
même temps mais rappelez vous de ce que
je vous ai dit il ya quelques secondes
déjà vous allez devoir choisir une de
ces cinq cartes mais ne vous laissez pas
influencer par exemple vous pouvez vous
dire que j'aime il a ce milieu pour vous
le preniez ou que le ci c'est différent
d'une couleur différente que ça c'est
pour vous induire à le choisir lui vous
choisissez la carte que vous voulez
librement complètement librement
maintenant allez-y avant de vous révéler
la carte que vous auriez dû choisir ou
que votre spectateurs du moins devrait
choisir je vais vous dire deux mots
quand même sur ce forçage ne l'est pas
de moi il est de banat tchèque qui s'est
inspiré à l'époque des travaux d'aider
leur donne pour créer ce forçage la
psychologie qui est très intéressant et
surtout très efficace
je vais vous mettre un lien dans le
descriptif qui vous renvoie vers tous
les livres qui a publié bana tchèque
c'est une mine d'or une ressource
surtout sur les forçages psychologique
vous invite vraiment à vous procurer ou
vous faire prêter ces livres là qui sont
extrêmement intéressants
en temps normal le spectateur choisit le
cadre de coeur après avoir hésité sur le
neuf de cartes
tout d'abord toutes les cartes que vous
allez cité il va pas les choisir parce
que vous mettez en avant leurs
différences et vous les avez cités dont
classe salle élimine complètement et la
carte noire celle élimine complètement
aussi dans la plupart des forces âge on
remarque que les extrêmes ne sont jamais
choisi qui plus est pour le roi qui est
une carte forte une valeur il sort lui
également du lot donc n'a pas envie de
le prendre
d'où cette hésitation sur le neuf des
carreaux mais encore une fois c'est un
extrême donc on a envie de cacher son
choix et il va se porter sur la carte
d'à côté leucate qui n'est pas très
visible qui al'air en fait anodin il est
tellement anodin que c'est lui le plus
différent des autres
alors au delà de cette application très
précise de banat tchèque j'aimerais vous
ouvrir l'esprit sur tout ce que vous
pouvez faire avec ça vous pouvez
l'adapter à plus de cartes à moins car
tu as des objets
également pourquoi pas à des mots à
toutes sortes de choses en réalité moi
je me suis servi de cette méthode et
d'autres méthodes pour créer la vidéo
que je vous mettre ici puis en lien sur
les croix ça fait partie des techniques
que j'ai employé pour faire cette vidéo
là je vous en dis pas plus si jamais
vous l'avez pas vu si vous avez d'autres
idées d'applications de type et de
forçage psychologique de cartes on peut
en parler dans les commentaires vraiment
ça fait plaisir je vous lis n'oubliez
jamais ça je vous lis tous
amusez vous bien et n'oubliez pas de
laisser un pouce en l'air avant de
partir et de vous abonner à la chaîne
puisque le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant toute une année depuis
le 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 17h chao je joue
mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre
à la garenne colombes c'est la date la
plus proche de paris si jamais vous
voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site